this is my job
this is my job
[Music]
hey there folks so um not really
a video on any of the normal topics i'm
gonna be a little bit self-indulgent and
celebrate
one year of professional
this um so i guess i'll
i mean i like first and foremost more
than anything
thank you the viewers the subscribers
youtube channel members the patreon
supporters
i would not be able to say that this was
my job
uh if it weren't for every single one of
you and the fact that this is my job is
amazing to me so
uh for anyone who's who's newer around
here
and wasn't watching prior to when this
happened uh or who just cares for a
recap
a year ago i was laid off
from my day job
a day job that i've been at for nine
years
and [ __ ] hated
i hated
that job so much
i i'm not gonna like get too
far into the weeds on this but uh
i never loved that job but i didn't hate
it for the entire nine years
so i'm not going to name the company i'm
not going to you know
it's it's i'm not going to be a jerk
about it but
i was working for a company that
actually physically made
stuff i started in customer service um
didn't like it there when i started um
but that was actually more of an issue
of my immediate co-worker who sat right
next to me
uh who i did not get along with at all
and who thankfully
uh was fired about i don't know
six months into into the job and uh
then the the inside sales person if if
you don't know inside sales
uh uh it handles the smaller accounts
um so uh the inside sales person left
for other work and the head of sales at
the time decided to experimentally
uh rather than hire a new inside sales
person try having the customer service
department
um take on the inside sales accounts
and see how that worked it didn't work
great but he did notice that i
was handling that kind of work better
not surprising i've had customer service
and also sales jobs before that
so i became the new inside sales manager
and
while i never loved it at no point did i
love it cause
my passion is in creativity my passion
is not
in calling up businesses to see
how much of the stuff we make they want
to buy this month
you know my passion is never going to be
there but i didn't hate it
um you know as far as day jobs go that
paid the bills it was
fine and honestly it
paid decently but that was where things
started to go downhill
because that there was there was a
stretch of time where i used to say
i don't really like my job but at least
they pay me well to not like it
yeah that didn't stay the case when
um the head of sales who initially
brought me in
when he uh moved on
and the person who took over
first thing they did was slash my
commission rate
i'm not going to get into the nuts and
bolts of exactly what they did or how
they did it but they didn't touch my
base salary
but my commission was slashed to the
tune
of me making 15
000 less
from the year before they did that to me
to the year when they did it they
cost me 15 grand
and i had no control i know that my only
option would have been to quit
i didn't because the job market where i
am sucks and it sucks especially if you
don't have a degree in anything which i
don't
and i was also looking at the fact that
any job i was really qualified for that
was actually going to cover my bills
decently was going to be based off my
work experience
and my work experience was doing the
crap i was already doing
i'd be rolling the dice on would i like
this other company better
you know if i could even find another
one to apply a
job for so i stuck it out
and then they screwed with my commission
rate again the next year
didn't hit me as hard but that's because
i didn't have
the same pool of income for them to ding
so that time it only cost me i don't
know
three four thousand dollars from the
year before but at this point like
they effectively slashed my take-home
pay
by almost 20 grand and if you think that
maybe at this point i was kind of
half-assing the job yeah no frankly i
was
frankly i was because they made it very
clear
that it didn't matter to them if i did
the job well
they weren't gonna pay me what they used
to pay me
and i'm sorry if you're gonna
screw me over that hard
i will do the work you tell me to do i'm
not gonna
be enthusiastic about it i'm not
offering up any more than is
asked of me so yeah i was kind of
checked out
for about two years went every day
was kind of checked out
and then covet happened and uh that
initially
meant working from home which meant even
less getting done because look
you know this is this is adhd added into
the mix
it it was hard enough for me to focus
on doing any work while i was physically
in the office
when there was very little else i could
actually be doing
than the work that i was assigned now
having to work from home
with adhd in a house where i have
literally a bajillion other things i say
literally
figuratively a bajillion other things
that i could be doing instead
with what is around me
and you expect me to get work done yeah
well you know
not even out of spite but like no i was
even less productive because
this is not gonna work for me like it's
just not
and then i got laid off in july of last
year
and it was the best thing
to happen to me in a long time
it was a relief even before
i made that information public which
then
resulted in a huge jump
to the patreon support way more like i
figured i'd get a little
way more than i ever could have
suspected even before that jump happened
i was relieved to not have to go to that
job anymore
and then the bump did happen and i found
myself thinking
i might actually be able to do this
and now here we are a year later it's
been it's
here's the thing i now love what i do i
love my job and
and anyone who knows me day to day can
tell you
i am a much happier person right now
than i was a year ago
i had a lot of bad mood days
those last couple years at that job
it infuriated me and i hated it so
so much to not only not have the weight
of that
but to do something that energizes me
i just i i i'm falling short of words
this has been absolutely life-changing
and i when i took the leap
i wasn't sure it was going to work and
now
that um the book is out and i
you know i've started
you know working on other writing
projects i
again this is working with my adhd i got
a chromebook
and i'll either um i've got a room
uh down downstairs
that i'll either write in there or on in
nice days in nicer weather i'll go out
on the porch and i'll write and i get so
much more done
um because i'm just on the on the
computer i edit on i'm just so used to
doing a bajillion things other than
writing
that my adhd kicks in and if i try and
write i'll get like a couple sentences
in and then my brain's like
check check this check twitter see if
there's comments that need moderating
work on this edit
et cetera et cetera but i take the
chromebook out to the porch
i ideally leave my phone inside but
i write and i write so much faster and
so much more productively
my work day now
consists of things like watching
movies taking notes
writing scripts in the sun
on a porch getting to sit down and talk
with you
that
this is my job
the the job i was at before
i'd been wondering for about a year if i
left
could i pull together what i would need
to be able to do the youtube full-time
and the doubt of that the the
fear of leaping and not making it
kept me there because like i'm not just
worried about myself i have a kid you
know i people depended on me so
if i was the only one who i had to care
for i i might have even
tried to do that well before this
but it felt irresponsible to
try and
while i kind of wish it had happened
sooner the
the circumstances of one of the worst
freaking
years on the planet
set me free
and you people
caught me
there's a lot that goes on
in the world in the things i talk about
in entertainment and just in general
that
can weigh on you and on me
but people cared
i lost my job and people cared
and came out to help
and are continuing to help are making
this
possible
i now literally have my dream job
and i made i made it a year
i'm really i'm really doing this
i had wondered am i gonna get
six months into this and realize i'm not
gonna be able to cover it and
look there were tight moments when i got
my tax bill
from 2020
that thing was scary i think was really
scary and i
i i was stressed about that
and like i'm headed into the you know
future tax
situations i think with a better
understanding of what it is i need to do
to be sure i'm prepped
uh and ready and and you know the things
i need to do to
have it not hurt as much but
even even the times between
when i got my tax bill when i was able
to pay it
while there was stress and it wasn't
fun i will
happily take
the financial stress of making sure
that i've got everything covered
while getting to do this over
financial security and a soul-crushing
job i will take
this always
every day i am so grateful
to be able to do this and by this i
don't just mean
this channel i mean the podcast
i mean tick-tock as silly as it is
the book
i wouldn't have had the time
to have the book out by now
if i was still stuck at that goddamn job
the support that i have built that you
have
shown me
has made so many amazing things possible
and i i literally cannot thank you
enough
i do not have words to thank you enough
so i will just simply say thank you
and here is to many
many more years whatever your thoughts
are or anything you want to say
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it
like share subscribe help me out
obviously there's the patreon
there's the link i
i i can't always use more support but i
i never want the fact that i continue to
push these things and
hope to grow things further to make it
seem like the support i have isn't
enough
the support i have is incredible
and it means the world to me
if you want to add some to that those
are ways to do it youtube memberships
etc etc but
you don't have to
which is part of what's wonderful about
the fact that
when i
forcibly had to take the leap that so
many of you came out to catch me
you didn't have to and you did it anyway
and that is what makes you
the council of geeks
while i am simply honored and privileged
to be able to run the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]